we can create something that is going
can input the next revolution we're part
of enabling the next revolution in the
cloud
that's meaningful that's taking the
world a couple of steps forward
and the last point is very personal and
that's the fact that
this is something that i have a peace in
like it's mine
so if i'm going to fail if i'm going to
succeed that's all going to impact my
it's very personal
experience and for me that that's part
of the effect of
being in a startup
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret corps adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
excel j impact leap google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
c-tech
hello and welcome to 20-minute leaders
today i have the honor of speaking with
eris berkner the ceo and co-founder of
lumigo a modern observability platform
for the modern cloud he attended the
open university of israel obtaining a
degree in computer science and
mathematics with honors and he worked at
checkpoint software technologies for
more than a decade and was director of
cloud-based security products before
starting lumiko a really really great
episode enjoyed every minute of it and i
hope you do as well
i love having you here we're going to
have a great conversation about your
journey about lumigo such an awesome
company you have some
you know a great great problem that
you're working on serverless monitoring
in the cloud
obviously the world is is transitioning
to the cloud i learned recently it's not
all in the cloud i grew up thinking that
everything is in the cloud but
apparently it's still a transition and
there's a lot of problems to be solved
backed by some phenomenal investors
great friends from grove pitango red
lane capital um looks like phenomenal
growth and i'm excited to hear a little
bit about the way you perceive the world
and how lumigo enters your own uh story
your own life story open university
checkpoint et cetera so eres thank you
again for being here
yeah um yeah thank you for for all this
i think this is you know very very
i know i i wish there were like a
podcast like this like you know 15 20
years ago um
i think uh
at the essence uh just to complete what
you're saying um
we're going through a transformation now
and it's very much
similar for the transformations that
you know aws started from like moving
from on-premise to the cloud we are now
in the stage of moving from cloud
1.0 to cloud 2.0 essentially all the new
technologies in the cloud it's no longer
just virtual machines
up there in the cloud
it's a container that kubernetes and
serverless and microservices so all the
buzzwords that you keep hearing in the
last couple of years they really come
together and they've formed a new
framework that on top of that developers
are building the next generation of the
cloud and
without getting too technical that looks
really different than how it used to
look like five years ago when a
developer wanted to develop an
application
and that brings new challenges and with
those new challenges um you see new
companies that are here to solve those
challenges specifically lumigo is
focused about allowing developers to run
those applications um with confidence
making sure that when something goes
wrong they would know about it and be
able to fix it
so that's kind of like just you know two
minutes about what omega is doing
i i think your question about you know
the story of of myself and how i connect
so
i'm a developer so
early on uh i started i loved developing
i started
you know i learned very early i went to
the open university during high school
and you know i i was a computer geek in
the sense of uh
today's note gig is everybody but i was
playing games before it was cool
computer games and i was programming
before it was cool
and
i ended up
in checkpoint and
as a developer after the
special unit in the idf
and i think at the end of the game
throughout my checkpoint uh i learned
about about the cloud and about the i
really got excited about that
transformation and as a developer that
really what brought me to you know to
dive deeper about how the future of
software is going to look like and that
brought me to
hey something is changing here and
they're going to be new tools that are
needed and this is how omega started
so take me back a little bit even even
further sort of your own curiosity as an
engineer as a developer thinking about
these emerging technologies these shifts
in technology
what what where does it come down to you
you know how you know what what sort of
how do you think through your own
curiosity about this what what started
this what led you to be to have that
insatiable curiosity that you're
describing here
that's a good question i think i think
you know throughout my career um
i was i was very much uh
i always aspired to
be involved with the latest technologies
so
uh when it was cloud then it was cloud
and virtualization and later on
serverless and conte so it always you
know the cutting-edge technology always
excited me
um and this is what where i you know i
automatically went to with within my
development failure career
and
um
that curiosity got me to you know to get
deeper and manage more of the let's get
it the checkpoint business that has to
do with those
technologies
and from that position
that's very interesting because i i was
able you know i was managing the
checkpoint cloud security uh products
at the end no
later 2015.
and that's very interesting because from
that position i was able to see things
that i couldn't have seen just as a
developer for example
a partnerships with microsoft and aws
all of a sudden i saw that they are
really pushing the new technologies the
serverless containers
and at the same time i started to see
that checkpoint customers are building
those technologies and are really
getting you know getting excited about
the
pace of innovations they provide
so it kind of i think gave me other
developer a unique view of
where the world is heading to
maybe two or three years before you know
the
average developer can see that
and i think you know that's really what
you need like to be at the right spot to
be able to see a bit further away and to
identify those you know once in a decade
revolution
and if you get there and you get a solid
feeling that's a great place to you know
to start a business and find a product
that means our problem with the solution
so were you actively looking at
different ideas or ideation for for
startups or was this something that you
came across you said wow i'm realizing
that i'm in this intersection of of time
product and understanding and so this is
an opportunity for me to start a company
how did that whole thing begin
it's actually a bit of both
so you know
i i think you know 50 of developers in
the last 10 years
are thinking about opening a startup at
one point or another that is relatively
that's the reality uh but there's a big
step to to take this to the next level
so i think it was always there
like waiting for the right time the
right um market the right problem the
right confidence
uh
and so you know the ground was there but
they then came serverless and containers
and all the modern cloud and that it
really hits like wow it really got me
excited
and that really gave me the confidence
for the first time in my life to come
and say i'm going all in on this and you
know leave everything aside and just
jumping into the pool incredible so tell
me you know the first few days of lumigo
obviously now if you're if you're
looking at you know
really fast growth awesome company but
how did the you know you're just
starting out you have this thesis about
where the world is changing sounds like
you have a great conviction about this
thesis it comes from the intersection of
you as a developer as an engineer but
then through checkpoint observing these
partnerships and these uh you know how
who's sort of what are the big elephants
that are pushing the tech industry and
and where people are getting excited by
how do you rationalize or strategy
strategize through the first steps of
building such a company
first of all it's really hard no
you just you stop doing what you're
doing and you're probably been good at
what you're doing and you're you're in
your comfort zone and all of a sudden
you're alone you know you wake up in the
morning there's nothing out there
there's no structure there's no
framework there's the best case you have
at least a founder with right
you don't have where to be like
you you have nothing
and that
nothingness
is really hard because you don't have
you need to to decide where to go and
you have like 360 open
um
and honestly at this time also you don't
know anything even if you have this you
really don't know and what do you know
at that moment so you know you are going
this journey what do you know in this
whole emptiness of nothingness
[Music]
so so the way i thought about it because
it's so empty is that um
let's get back to basics like
something is happening that's not
related to us something is happening in
the cloud there is a revolution there is
a new
a um
architecture being built that gonna
shake the cloud so
whatever i'm gonna do
i don't know maybe or at the end of the
day it's monitoring it's security i
don't know what's going on over there i
have say this but i'm probably gonna
change them but as long as i'm going to
stick to this revolution
and i'm going to spend my time over
there and i'm going to be the expert of
that
and then i'll be able to there's going
to be so many opportunities in that like
in the cloud 15 years ago
that if you spend your time there you're
going to find so many opportunities to
grow a business and to grow a company
and then it goes to identify those in
execution
so that's kind of like the basic you
know i don't know if that's the exact
idea but i know that that's the domain i
want to double double down on awesome
okay so you're saying sort of like
very similar to how investment thesis
happened you're saying there's this
big blue ocean here there's a trend
there's a consumer shift that's
happening i know there's potential here
and i'm going to now go on a journey to
identify exactly how to harness the
potential of it but i know that it's
there and i have the right partners to
do this with
take me back now back to the sort of the
thesis that you came up with on on the
way the developers are interacting with
their serverless you know
applications and machines
yeah so
you know quite honestly when we started
you know i'm coming from 14 years a
checkpoint so i'm a security expert
and you know new technology is
serverless so it only makes sense
serverless with security here startup
like several security
um
so and that will allow me to leverage
all of the experience that they have
so this is where we actually started in
the first early days um i think one of
the things that we
you know we knew again that we don't
know we knew that everything is in our
mind and we have no validation so we
strive to get
as fast as possible early stage
validation
what we basically did is we went to
40 organizations
before writing a line of code we have a
created presentation
this you know mock-up and you know now
pictures of how screens can look in the
product
we contacted 40 companies that we were
able to get to and they were able to
willing to listen to us and told them
you know you have serverless you're
you're adopting that here's a an idea
does that make sense to you is that the
problem that you want to solve but
that's all the problem would you pay for
this
uh and we learned
you know very quickly that
nobody out of those 40 maybe one really
cared about said yeah server security is
a big problem for me
uh so that was very no it took us about
three four weeks to say wow that's you
know it's not mature enough something is
not there yet
but but at the same time
most of them told us but you know we're
earlier stage we're still trying to
build that so if you can do something to
help us
build and have confidence to run it in
production
that is something that is game changer
and this is basically shifted us toward
monitoring and debugging and how do you
identify sort of the big gaps because
there's a lot of different offerings and
in in cloud technologies and all the way
from the big players like jcpaws all the
way to to smaller startups how do you
sort of identify
you know really the the pain points that
you're going to solve and how you're
creating differentiation amongst amongst
competitors i know this is a generic
question but but i think it begs it in
in such an emerging space that you have
so many different cloud companies that
are providing offerings in the past
years especially from israel
right
so i think there are you know remember
we were very early stage to a
drastically radical new technology
so
you know and we knew that you know the
incumbents
will it will take them a long time to
get up to speed so
competitive wise we knew that if we'll
be uh one of the first and we'll execute
that would be a good position
at the same time you know we found a
problem the pro not because we you know
because we heard it from
from company help us to run
application in production with the new
technologies in a safe way again it's
monitoring its debugging
so we knew that that's a domain that if
we can help them they will pay for it it
provides them it literally stops them
from being able to innovate and to
iterate right i mean this is the bread
and butter of what is what technology
company does is to
create new applications in production
iterate on them and be able to solve
problems quickly right it's like the
fundamental layer exactly
exactly and and if there is a problem
that's critical you know that's your
business that is right so if i can help
no two hours of downtime that can be
millions of dollars sure
so so that that's where we actually
drilled down so we didn't stop there we
came back to those 40 companies said
okay we got you we came with a new idea
with new presentation this is what we
want to do and then it's it you know to
your point goes down to the details of
he wants this and he wants this and we
try to get you know those kind of like
uh
buckets of uh features together which
really allowed us to get to the first
design partners well so what is lumigo
you know
few years down the line you you met you
meet the milestones you mean this what
is the role of lumigo in in the world
today
so
the world is changing as i mentioned
people are adopting the cloud 2.0 with
the new technology
and
throughout the years there were always
an ecosystem going with
every server every cloud that you have
so lumigo is going to be the
um the monitoring tool of choice for all
the new cloud architecture so you go to
the cloud you use the new technology you
deploy lumigo to monitor your
environment that that's kind of like
that's your stack that's a repeatable
model that everybody's gonna all the
modern startup and organization i'm
going to choose because omega is is the
best option and why do you care so much
as i know why it's important but why do
you care so much that you wake up every
day
leading this ship and and telling that
narrative
why do you care
i i think you know
it's a
it's it's not a
couple of reasons
one i think at the very basic
um the new technologies excites me and
that's where we started like the concept
of you know again serverless containers
kubernetes it's it's
it's so fast it's so cool it's so
you know i used to do things way back
you know very technical c drivers linux
that's kind of like the old wood i was
in a checkpoint
so it really got me excited that's one
and understanding that i you know we can
create something that is going can input
the next revolution we're part of
enabling the next revolution in the
cloud
that's meaningful that's taking the
world a couple of steps forward
and the last point is very personal and
that's the fact that
this is something that i have a peace in
like it's mine
so if i'm going to fail if i'm going to
succeed that's all going to impact my
it's very personal
experience and for me that that's part
of the effect of
being in a startup being
power you're having a piece
of building or whatever it is you're
building i mean i think part part of
what excites me in companies like lumigo
is sort of this a basic you know sort of
the butterfly effect that if flamigo
does it works properly
and makes a positive impact on
organizations this in turn allows the
organizations that are more i guess
consumer facing or more application
based to to be able to iterate faster to
increase the rate of innovation add to
sort of the super evolution that we talk
about in innovation endeavors it's sort
of how do you how do you create
infrastructure layers that allow
organizations at scale to operate faster
and with more confidence right
[Music]
exactly and today it's
no i don't want to sound but but it's
broken so you see you know the top
challenges all the time for the new
cloud is debugging monitoring and
observability so if we can take those
away you know we're on a highway for
fast adoption of the entire world of the
modern
technologies and faster pace of
development but it is we've been in the
cloud almost for 10 years at least from
my experience i've been working on cloud
applications for the last 10 years
why are we still in 2022 and it's such a
pressing problem that you're describing
today what's i mean maybe maybe it's
considered fast and you know the scope
of of sort of innovation as humanity in
general but but to me it seems a little
bit slow given how pressing and and
urgent it is
yeah
so i i think you're right it has to do
with maybe the the human
factor and the human economy because
you know you can see trends of
technology nothing really goes though
it's very rare that something goes away
especially like fast it's always coming
on top of
so you know it takes many many tens of
years for things to really go away
so this is what we saw you know when
moving to virtualization and then moving
to virtual machines in the cloud and now
moving to kubernetes and serverless
you know it's it's
even the cloud by the way is about ten
to twenty percent of the overall servers
of the world ten twenty percent that's
crazy right and it's crazy right you
feel like everybody's in cloud
unbelievable but you have industries
that are you know legacy industries
things just work
and and that that's the majority of the
world in the world today so it takes
time for things to adopt and the same
goes here there's like a new technology
and it will run you know hand in hand
with virtual machines and even with
on-premise servers for many years to
come
but at the same time the overall cake is
also growing more applications are being
built so the market is growing itself i
mean it sounds like it it still has five
at least five times to grow and and
obviously we're introducing more
more infrastructure every year and i
think i think that's fascinating and i
keep reminding myself sort of this
bubble that i'm in where yeah i see all
around me innovation and you know
cloud-based things but most of the world
is still on physical servers and and
it's such a fundamental idea and and
obviously i hope that lumiko plays a
strong part in the confidence boost and
the ability to to to migrate and to
manage cloud applications because i'm
excited most about the end application
layer of how consumers are how our lives
are becoming better through technology
but at the end it's all based on this
infrastructure layer that you're
providing
with monitoring debugging and confidence
which is all things that are blocking
innovation and blocking iteration
thank you very very much this is such a
pleasure
thank you very much
[Music]